we're going to be talking about coding
complex applogic visually so we all know
how to code app logic and coding complex
app logic is something that gets of
course a little bit more cumbersome
Harrier and I'm going to show you how by
using something called a visual
formalism we could actually make it a
lot easier to code this complex app
logic but first of all how does applogic
get complex so here's a very simple
example and this is in react if you know
react then you're going to you're going
to probably find this example
entertaining and if you don't know
reacts then you're going to find this a
lot more entertaining just because
you're going to be like what the heck is
going on so uh over here we have an on
submit event and so when we're
submitting the form we're submitting the
data but as anyone who's builds a form
knows this is not the entire story right
we have to have some sort of indicator
that we're actually loading the data so
we have to have some is loading States
Boolean variable in there and then we
have to set that is loading to true but
you see the problem here this loading
spinner is going to keep going on and on
because we're not turning it off so we
have to add a resolution to that promise
where when the promise is done you know
we might set our data we might do
something with it but we need to set
that loading spinner to false or that
loading flags of false so that we don't
see the loading spinner
but then there's the other problem where
we have to actually handle errors so
with errors you know now we have to set
another variable and then we have to set
the error when we get the error but we
also have to make sure that we're hiding
the loading spinner and I've seen this
happen a bunch of times where you still
see the loading spinner but you see an
error or worse you will see applications
and trust me go ahead and play around
with applications you're going to see
this happen in at least a few of them
where you do something it's loading and
loading and loading and you're like okay
are you done loading this is a really
big file what's going on so you're like
you know what let me take a peek inside
the console and then you realize wow
there's actually a huge error and the UI
decided not to tell me anything about it
so these are all edge cases or not even
edge cases these can be pretty easily
run into by any normal user and these
are all things that you have to think
about but it gets even more complex than
that you know we have to also think
about cancellation what if we want to
cancel a promise cancel fetching data
now we have to handle that as well
otherwise we're going to be running into
race conditions so this is just one very
very simple example of code where things
can get out of hand pretty quickly now
this might just be one feature multiply
this by however many features you have
in your app and you could see how how
complexity just grows even exponentially
over time
and there's many reasons for this
there's the addition of features the
more features you add the more
complexity you're going to get by
definition adding features doesn't
necessarily remove complexity in fact
that very rarely happens there's also
changes to features and you're never
sure whether like changing a feature is
actually going to affect other features
just because in your application
features are all interconnected and of
course the more features you have and
the more requirements you have the more
bugs you're going to have so you have to
also fix those bugs now I would love to
say that the best way to fix a bug is to
delete code but more often than not when
you fix bugs you're actually adding code
or at the very least modifying code and
then there's the issue of adding
developers and developers leaving your
team whether you like it or not there's
a lot of institutional knowledge that
lives only in the developer's head so
that when they leave the company or when
they switch teams are when they work on
something else all of a sudden that
knowledge stays with them and it might
be hard to get a hold of them they might
not always be available and so you get
complexity as a result and then of
course even if we didn't have any of
those things there's always us you know
the nature of developers trying to chase
shiny new things uh you know there's a
new framework every week in the
JavaScript landscape and I'm not sure
how it is in the back and Landscape I I
hope that there's not as much churn as
the front-end landscape but and if there
is I'll become a or if there isn't I'll
become a back-end developer that sounds
like fun
um but one of the biggest problems that
I've seen or well like I guess one of
the biggest symptoms of this is that we
write code that that's the number one
way that we write our programs is by
just writing code and the way we write
code of course is to be understood by
other developers here's the problem
though code is text it's primarily text
and text you read in three ways you read
left to right just like a book top to
bottom in file by file and this is
especially true when you're reviewing
PRS typically how I review PRS is I just
go file by file try to read it and it
doesn't really make sense it's hard to
piece together a picture of what the
developer was thinking when they were
writing all of that code and so it
occurred to me that code is linear but
programs are not necessarily linear I
mean just uh think about you know the
earliest basic programs where we have
all those go-to's you would read it
linearly until you see a go to and then
you would have to shift your eyes up to
a line so really code is more like one
of those choose your own adventure
stories where you have a function call
now you have to switch contexts in your
brain and read that function and try to
understand the context that function was
called in when you're going back to the
original code that you were originally
reading so
yeah
um
here's one example from slack I'm not
sure how many of you have seen this
before but this is a decision tree or a
flow chart whatever you want to call it
for when slack decides to send a
notification and so this is just one
small part of business logic that um you
know in slack and of course slack is a
very complex program I'm not sure
whether this is on the front end this is
probably on the back end I guess or
maybe the front end but there's a lot of
decisions to be made just for deciding
whether not to show a notification or to
show a notification and so you could see
this is something that's very hard to
describe in a linear way
so that's why you know spoiler alert
having this in a visual format actually
makes things a lot clearer than having
it in a text-based format but when we
think about low code we sort of think
about things like this how many of you
remember this right this is how I
started programming with uh I was going
to say vs code this is not vs code this
is Visual Basic and so what was cool
about Visual Basic is it allowed you to
drag and drop certain things on the
screen and then you could program each
of those elements and you had a nice
visual representation of what your
program was going to look like and you
didn't need to write everything by code
a lot of the visual elements again could
just be tracked and dropped on the
screen but of course right now we're
sort of of the opinion where when we
look at low code AS developers we're
like maybe no thanks maybe I just want
to stay with code because code gives me
the most full flexibility
but in reality uh us developers we do
use low code in a way and so we use low
code no code to supplements the code
that we're already creating so two great
examples are TL draw and excalator and
um I'm sure a lot of you might be
familiar with Excalibur TL draw is
another fantastic drawing tool that's
just like Excalibur and both of them are
very helpful when you're creating
architecture diagrams or simple flow
charts or things like that to easily
draw and show your team just diagrams
for what you're trying to express and of
course these can be related to the code
and it's very nice to see these diagrams
alongside your documentation or as a way
of explaining the code that you have
that you're working with so two
extremely useful tools I use them pretty
much every day
and then we look at other Industries for
example graphic design there's tools
like
procreates there's video editing tools
like
um Adobe has a whole Suite of tools
Photoshop illustrator
um there's DaVinci Resolve and so all of
these tools are professional tools these
aren't simple tools where it's like oh I
just want to make a simple picture or
create a simple video when you get into
really Advanced editing you're not given
an IDE where you have to code everything
you're given a very detailed and
advanced visual interface in which you
could create these things and it's not
limited to just those there's also game
developments and computer assisted
Design This is Unity Blueprints and this
is AutoCAD and of course these are all
visual tools that professionals use
every day and even with websites and
apps there's tools like uh like plasmic
and framer for web and you know there's
webflow too and all of these are visual
tools that help us create applications
and they're not even just limited to uh
to novice developers or so-called
citizen developers but also to just um
you know Advanced developers could use
these kinds of tools as well
uh but of course the the vast majority
of what we're working on today uses Ides
such as vs code or webstorm or notepad
plus plus if some of you are still using
that but here is a core problem when
we're working with teams we have code
and we have other sources of Truth so
code is not the only source of Truth we
also have user stories and user flows in
the form of diagrams and mock-ups from
designers and of course we also need to
write tests which live separately from
our code base for whatever reason and
then we have these tutorials which sort
of just fits in with documentation as
well and the problem is that none of
these are written in the same language
we have a Tower of Babel situation in
which all of these just sort of clash
and nobody is talking the same language
on the team and so if we split the team
into three types of personas we see that
each one of them has their own language
or their own way of sort of talking
about pretty much the same thing with
designers again you have mock-ups that
you might make in figma or user flows
stakeholders might be writing and
project managers might be writing user
stories requirements specifications
tutorials as well and developers of
course we're writing code and tests to
implement all of the above but again
these are at minimum three completely
different languages
so it's my goal today to just try to
find that common language that all our
entire team can use
and um so when we talk about like a user
story or a specification I I really like
to use this kind of flow these boxes and
arrows so for example we have this user
story where given the user is logged out
when the user logs in with the correct
credentials then the user should be
logged in now notice that with these
boxes and arrows we're basically saying
this and we're doing it in a visual way
you know logged out when we log in with
correct credentials the arrow points to
logged in now this could be useful for a
project manager or a designer but as a
developer you might need more detail and
so this is something where we could
easily refine the diagram to say okay as
a developer here's the things I care
about and as a designer or a project
manager or a stakeholder I only care
about the higher level things in these
details don't really matter directly to
me
and so you could do this for your entire
application so yeah in an application
you could think of as a series of just a
lot of user stories all coming together
and so each one of these user stories
might be a couple of those boxes in one
of those arrows or even more than one
arrow and so when you put all of that
together you realize that they make a
directed graph now if you don't know
what a directed graph is it's just a
graph where you have nodes which in this
case those are all of the circles over
there and edges which connect each of
the nodes and the directed part means we
are going in a specific direction from
one node to one Edge so for example if
you're logged out that might be a node
and so if you click login that might be
an edge that goes to a logging in node
and then lather rinse repeat for your
entire app and then if you zoom out
you're going to realize that your app is
just a series of these no notes and
edges all connected to each other
so one of the best ways that I found and
I found this quite a few years ago to
express this is something called a state
machine and now a lot of you might be
familiar with the same machine but if
you're not then I'll just describe it to
you real quick a sting machine is
basically a directed graph where you
have again all of these notes and edges
which are connected with these directed
arrows so seat machines have five parts
and this is their mathematical
definition they have an initial state
which is the state that the state
machine always starts in they also have
a series of states and these states are
finite so you could think of a state as
representing the behavior or when I talk
about Behavior I mean what can happen
when it is provided in an event so when
the machine word sees an event it's
going to do something different
depending on which state it's in and so
these are the events and so events can
come from anywhere events are things
that happen so for example check out you
could interpret as someone clicking a
checkout button and we're going to see
an example of that pretty soon clicking
next this could be a next button or
pressing the right arrow key on your
keyboard so these are all things that
happen and transition You from One
State's to another and these transitions
are depicted with these arrows over here
showing that when I'm in the states and
an event is received I will immediately
transition to another state or I might
stay in the same state and maybe do
something else
and of course State machines might also
have final States and this is when the
state machine is pretty much done and no
other operations can occur
so I I found State machines to be very
useful not only for you know back-end
workflows but also for the front end
this is an example UI where uh you know
we're just we have a password protected
screen and there's a bunch of different
states that this could be in and so uh
this is actually on codepen I forgot to
add the link over here but this shows
you how it's transitioning through all
the different states as we're trying uh
different passwords and you see you know
it went to the success date
now uh some of the benefits of State
machines are well first of all they
prevent impossible States and you might
think that impossible States you know
rarely happen but again play around with
apps you're going to see uh you know
things like the loading spinner still
occurring uh when you see an error uh or
you know things like that so just things
that don't make sense and so impossible
States might be a nuisance at best but
they could entirely break the app and
the experience for the user at worst and
so if you take anything from this talk
especially if you're like you know what
I don't want to use steep machines I
don't want to use x data or any of these
fancy libraries then please just take
this when you have Boolean variables
such as is loading is Success has errors
things like that and they're actually
all mutually exclusive please consider
using an enum value instead and so even
if you're not using a type system this
could be something as simple as
assigning a string instead of a boom
million value because strings contain a
lot more information in context than
each of the Boolean variables you have
you know true or false that's it but
when you have an enum now it's
impossible to be in like more than one
of these states but over here if it's
loading is true and is success is true
you know that's an impossible States and
you can't have that over here
so how do we make State machines the
truth is you don't actually need a
library to make these State machines you
could use a simple switch statement and
so many of you if you've used Redux or
something similar you might have done
this before however there's one big
difference and the difference is that
we're not switching on the events but
instead we're switching on the state's
value instead and so the state value
could be that you know loading error
success and then we determine what to do
based on the events that we receive so
it's sort of a switch in thinking we're
not going event first we're going States
first but again another thing that if
you took one thing or now two things
from this talk is that at the very least
model your application logic using
events
instead of directly manipulating the
states by doing it in this way we're
sort of training ourselves that uh
events are important and everything that
could happen in the app can be in events
that's dispatched and it makes your
application logic a lot clearer to
understand as well and it also makes it
a lot more flexible because now for
example pressing the enter button or
clicking a button those could both send
the same events and again we'll see an
example of that soon
another way that I like to make Steam
Machines is using objects and that's
because I don't really like writing
switch statements so with objects it's
actually pretty convenient because I
could just put it in this special data
structure where I have all of my states
in the state object and then all of my
transitions in each of the states in
this on object where I I could add
multiple events here if I want but we
have the events and then we have the
next state where it should be in and
then once you've done that it's just an
object lookup so we're taking the
current state which for example might be
might be cart and then we're looking up
the state objects of States carts and
then we're looking up what the what the
event is and what the transition is
going to be so we look at on events type
and so in this case it's checkout and so
we know what the next event is going to
be and so again this is without using
any libraries you could use this today
um and it's just a really great way of
containing your logic in a state machine
in a very very simple way
now of course uh there's also libraries
for seat machines and the one that I'm
going to talk about is called X dates so
I created this Library about six or
seven years ago and the purpose of it is
to allow you to create steam machines
and state charts in JavaScript and
eventually we're going to be working on
other languages as well but with xdate
if you notice it's pretty much that
exact same object structure
so it's just taking that and it's
wrapping that in this create machine
function and then we have an interpret
function that actually takes that
machine and makes it alive it creates an
instance of that machine called an actor
that we could send events to and we
could subscribe to it so that we could
know when the state changes now it does
a lot more things than this and again
we're going to be looking at a couple of
demos pretty soon but um yeah this is
pretty much it so
um yeah I encourage you to you know just
check out X8 and we'll take a look at
the demo soon
um so one of the great things about
State machines is that you could
identify logical flaws and these logical
flaws might be things that your IDE or
your language server might not even
detect so for example
um and this is a logical flaws that are
pretty much at the business logic level
not necessarily at the code level so
while for example this state machine
might look perfectly fine you might have
a project manager or designer look at it
and say hey we're missing a few arrows
for example we might be missing a back
arrow for the contact page or the
payment page and you could say as a user
I should be able to go back or from the
payment page I should be able to cancel
and when I cancel my payment it should
take me back to the cart screen and so
this is an example I've heard many
stories where people would take the
steam machines that they created show
other people on their team who aren't
developers and they are the ones who are
able to say hey we're missing this or
this arrow is pointing to the wrong
place so it becomes again a low no code
way of expressing your application logic
and also speaking of expressing
application logic you could map your
state machine to stories to these user
stories and the other way around for
example this transition over here could
map to the user story as a user when I'm
in the carts and I click checkout I
should be taken to the shipping page and
then we could have another story where
as a user when I'm in the carts and I
check out via Paypal since PayPal has
all of my information I should be taken
to the payment page if you're not
familiar PayPal is a payment processor
it's a European thing too I think it's
International anyway I'm not sure what
you all use uh so um also there's a lot
of really really cool things that you
could do with directed graphs and I'm
really excited to show you this actually
but algorithms lots of graph algorithms
one of my favorite is dijkstra's
shortest path algorithm so because
you're expressing your app logic as a
directed graph now you could say hey
find me the shortest path that takes me
from the initial state to the final
state which is the confirmation screen
and then it could say okay the shortest
path is through here you go to the cart
you click PayPal you're taken to the
payment screen and then once you click
order now you're on the confirmation
page
or you could tweak that a little bit
where you could say find me the shortest
path where my shipping address is
provided and obviously we're not
providing the shipping address through
PayPal so the algorithm is going to
Traverse all of the edges and determine
that hey we need to go through here and
we need to go through that shipping
state in order to uh to have that
shipping address provided and so it's
going to find a different shortest path
and then you could tie this to analytics
or things like that and especially as
you grow your application
um the shortest path algorithm just
works really well for determining all of
these different paths throughout your
application and then you could use that
for generating documentation or
generating tests and that's exactly what
I'm going to show you right now
so um we're close enough to Denmark and
I made this little Lego checkout app uh
we're actually not really close to bill
and it's a few hours away but I was
really inspired by you know uh the Lego
checkout page especially because they
use xdate so I'm gonna I made a little
demo of that over here and just to show
you how it works if I click checkout
securely I could choose a shipping
address choose the shipping method
um you know enter some information
um
click payment and then once I click
agree I could place my order and then
I'm taken to the confirmation page or
much simpler I could just click pay via
PayPal and since it has all my
information I could just place the order
and then I'm taken to the confirmation
page so how does this app logic work it
works by using a machine so a state
machine I'm going to show you exactly
what that looks like over here
so this machine has all of the states in
it so we have cart we have shipping
contact payment and Confirmation and so
the transitions are over here so when I
select the shipping address we're not
changing states we're just assigning
that shipping address and when we select
a shipping method you know we do the
same thing but once we click next we go
to the next date so in this case we're
going to the contact page but only if we
have a valid shipping address now this
is a big Json object so it might be
easier for us to actually you know
visualize that so I'll show you how
that's done over here if I go to the
right page
okay index.js because we wrote this as a
state machine we could visualize it as a
state machine and so there's this
inspect utility from x-state inspect
where once I press save over here it's
going to open this machine and not sure
if you could see that very well but this
is the state machine visualized over
here so you know we have the carts we
have shipping contact payments and
Confirmation and we see that once like
if we go through PayPal we're taken
directly to the payment screen now
what's cool about this is this visual
this visualizer is actually directly
connected to the app so if I click check
out over here it's actually going to
take me to the shipping address and then
I could choose a shipping address
continue to contact information and it's
going to change the state over here so
you could actually see it happen in real
time
but I did talk about I'm going to just
hide this for a minute because I did
talk about another thing and that's the
generation of things like documentation
and tests again we talked about how we
could use shortest path algorithms to
generate all of these paths through the
app and so what I'm going to do is I
have this fine scenario function where
we have a whole bunch of checkout
scenarios generated from that state
machine and I'm going to find the
confirmed scenario where the state
matches confirmation
and so from that I'm going to generate
two things I'm going to generate the
steps that go through the machine and
determine what is the shortest path to
get to the confirmation and I'm also
because this is a react app and you can
do this with anything reacts views Felts
angular I'm going to automatically
generate all of the views in order to
get to each of those steps so now that I
did that we see that we have Auto
generated steps on the shopping cart
paid via PayPal on the payments agree to
the terms and conditions and then place
your order and then you will reach order
confirmed now this is coming from the
machine over here I have a bunch of meta
information so like this shipping
address and so for each of the events I
have a description where it's select a
shipping address all of this lives
inside the code so I'm not having to
maintain a separate file or a separate
documents to automatically generate
these steps now let's say that I didn't
want to to generate just the the PayPal
scenario because I actually wanted to
find the scenario where we actually do
provide a
a shipping address so I'm going to do
and
scenario.state.context Dot shipping
address so basically we're checking do
we also have a shipping address so
hopefully if I save this
it will automatically generate all of
those steps that take me through that
state machine
and generate each one of these steps and
also each one of the views over here so
it's simulating what's actually
happening when the user goes through the
entire flow
so yeah that's an example of using
using a state machine to generate
documentation and things like that
but State machines are not perfect and I
I'll be the first to admit that one of
the biggest problems with State machines
is called State and transition explosion
and that's when you have more and more
States and more and more Transitions and
since a lot of these can connect to
others you have a combinatorial
explosion of these states and
Transitions and it could be a little
unwieldy and start to look like this
spaghetti soup over here and hard to
visualize and so that's why there's a
formalism called State charts which
extends the notion of State machines and
provides a lot of other features so one
of the features it provides is this
notion of actions or these effects that
you could attach to Transitions and so
these are transition actions but you
could also simplify these by putting
them inside of the states and saying
whenever I enter the state we're going
to fetch data whenever I exit we're
going to log Telemetry and so all of
these action are part of the formalism
of State charts
and so some other important things
there's compound states where you could
Nest States inside of a parent state so
when I transitioned to the ready States
we're in the playing State
um and then when when I transition out
then you know we're in the loading
States
um and so you could transition between
these playing and pause dates once
you're in the parent States there's also
parallel states which allow you to
specify different regions or
responsibilities within your app so if I
have a music player I might have two
responsibilities which is the player
itself whether it's playing or paused
and the volume whether it's muted or
unmuted and so there's a ton of other
features like guarded transitions the
ability to raise events or send events
to self delayed transitions event list
transitions where a transition is
immediately taken history States and a
lot more and so um I have a quick one
more demo for you and so with this we're
going to be going the other way so
instead of of directly creating the
state machine over here we are or sorry
instead of working with the same machine
over here we're going to be creating a
state machine and this is going to be a
much simpler app but you're going to see
still how State machines are useful in
this app what I want to do is when I
click this video I want it to open up
full screen and start playing and then
when I exit the video and there's a
number of ways I could exit it I want it
to stop playing but also once the video
stops I want it to stop playing or and
go back to the mini mode after a few
seconds
so let's go ahead and model this right
now so I um right now this is actually
stately.ai editor which is in a uh a
free editor for State machines and so I
have this mini State over here I'm going
to create a full State over here and so
this is when the video player is full so
um I'm just going to say full screen
video player and just have that over
here
and so this is going to be toggled when
let's just make a toggle event
so I could toggle back and forth between
mini and full salt just put toggle over
here
but there's a couple of other events
that could happen that causes me to go
back to the mini state so for example
I'll just move this up here uh when the
video
ends
then we need to go back to the mini
State and also
when the Escape key is pressed so I have
this essay in Escape key event over here
now in order to get these events we also
have to invoke some listeners basically
or actors in other words so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to just add
these so we're going to be listening for
the video ended event and we're also
going to be listening for the key Escape
events and so these are going to be
things that just while we're in this
dates it's going to be listening for the
video ending events and the key Escape
events
and at the same time we also want to
play and pause the video too so when we
enter this full screen State we want to
play the video
and when we exit we want to pause the
video
um okay so I think that looks pretty
good except we were talking about State
charts so what I'm going to do is also
add a couple of child States so this is
going to be playing
and
we also want to have some sort of delay
when the video is stopped
so now instead of this video ended event
being here we actually want that video
ended events to be right over here so
that we could wait a couple seconds
before we go back to the mini state so
I'm going to just make this an after
transition so we're going to say after
and let's set it to two seconds so 2 000
milliseconds
all right now let's actually make sure
that this logic works I'm going to click
simulate over here and so we could you
know play pretend with our live diagram
that we made and let's toggle back and
forth once we toggle we're going back
between the mini and the full screen and
also when we're in the full screen we
could of course press the Escape key
which should take us back to the Mini
screen
but if we're watching the video and the
video ends then after two seconds we
should transition back to the Mini
screen okay so now that we have our
diagram in place let's go ahead and
start coding it and to do that all I'm
going to do is export the code because I
don't have that much time so we're just
going to copy all of this to the
clipboard and then I'm going to put this
in our machine over here and hopefully
it works all right so now I have my
logic and I've already attached event
listeners and things like that so if I
click here
not working
let's see oh I it literally says David
don't forget this so uh oops
there we go so now we're adding an event
listener to the uh to the click and so
now when I click
and I toggle out it's going to close the
video
also when I press the Escape key
it closes it and when I allow the video
to end hopefully after two seconds one
two
it goes back to many so there you go
and so that's just one example of how
visual programming can actually be
really helpful because we're not only
making it easier to um to express
application logic and to create it but
we're making it easier for other people
on the team to understand it and by
other people I don't just mean
non-developers I mean the rest of the
developers on your team because the way
that we typically code is we put logic
and event handlers and callbacks and
just some ad hoc logic floating around
everywhere and so with the rise of Redux
and flux and these types of events
driven Frameworks we've begun to be a
little bit smarter and put all of these
in reducers instead where events might
change some data within the reducer
Steam Machines take that a little bit
further and instead they separate this
data into different states and they give
you a more structured way of organizing
the different states and transitions
that comprise your application logic and
of course State charts take that even
further allowing you to describe
declarative effects to Nest states to
make them parallel and to handle a lot
more than normal State machines and then
we could get even further so uh we could
like one state chart describes the
behavior of a single entity but we could
have a lot of entities talking to each
other and these are called actors now
actors are things that could send and
receive events and we don't have too
much time to go into this right now but
an actor model if you've been working in
the front end you might not be familiar
but in the back end with microservices
and things like that the actor model is
actually really prevalent there's a lot
of rules that actors may have where it's
basically entities sending and receiving
events to each other and so one of the
best ways I have of describing like what
an actor is is like ordering a coffee
you have two different actors the a
barista in the person who's ordering a
coffee and in order for that transaction
to take place they actually have to talk
to each other so this idea of message
passing extends Beyond just normal human
communication it's actually a really
good way of expressing how different
parts of your code your applications
your microservices every part of your
code base can talk to each other and so
that's why I think having things in an
events driven way is really good because
by using events you have these arrows
which can visually describe just how
everything interacts with each other and
you know besides State machines and
state charts you also have you know
actor system architectures and sequence
diagrams and these allow you to really
take the requirements that you're given
by designers and project managers and
code in a simple visual way and make it
really easy to express your application
lot
so in general whether you're coding
um you know just front end back-end
applications no matter how much
complexity there is using these visual
diagrams can really help you simplify
the application logic and make it so
that your entire team can understand it
and that's why I think the future of
development is visual so with that thank
you very much orda